thank you very much uh alex for the
introduction and for the invitation to
this workshop it's really been a great
week so far
so today and uh as we briefly mentioned
yesterday
we will discuss a new application
in coding which deals with
a broad range of non-volatile memories
and here is a
collection of new applications that are
definitely primed for innovations in
coding theory
okay as we mentioned yesterday uh
non-volatile memories just think of them
as flash for the moment they offer fast
access and require less power
consumption than hard disk drives and
they are quite ubiquitous ranging from
uh digital personal electronics to cloud
storage in the form of ssd drives
flash memories are based as a prime
exemplar of non-volatile memories are
based on a large array of floating gate
transistors
information is stored by uh
capturing the electrons on the floating
on the floating gate of these
transistors and that is how we store the
information
however
even though this technology is extremely
promising and it's bound to replace hard
disk drives in many applications and it
already has indeed replaced hard disk
drives
there are certain uh challenges or
shortcomings that uh that need to be
overcome so in particular wear out and
reduce device lifetime have now become a
central issue
so
the endurance in terms of the uh device
actually decays very fast it decays
exponentially fast and uh
while we are increasing the density of
the device only two or threefold so this
is an extremely unfavorable trade-off
and it's due to a number of uh different
due to a number of different reasons and
they have to do with the way we access
these devices so i'm just going to
highlight some of the
major reasons for this and then we'll
see
how some new coding techniques can help
overcome these uh physical limitations
so rat asymmetry
in a nutshell increasing a cell level is
easy so let's say zero is a lower level
and one is a higher level if you want to
go from zero to one that means you're
injecting charge for the moment let's
assume that's easy
decreasing a cell level meaning removing
a charge is hard the reason for this and
this has to do with the way these cells
are organized is due to the physical
architecture of these cells is that you
have to access the entire block and
erase an entire block that means you
have to access and erase millions of
cells even though in principle you may
want to only erase one so you are maybe
in a situation when you're erasing and
updating cells that in reality should
not be updated
interstellar interference paul already
talked a little bit about this yesterday
so we've seen a new coding approach to
this
uh interstellar interference means that
programming a cell may impact adjacent
cells you may inadvertently raise the
level of an adjacent so-called victim
cell
charge leakage
cell levels decrease over time so these
are not perfectly chiseled machines they
actually wear out and so they leak
charge so what you store
is not necessarily going to equal to
what you read later on
and so this whole compounded effect
amounts to
what is known as a finite lifetime so
this is one of the peculiarities of
these devices
a device can only be programmed finally
many times before it is deemed
unreliable and so our goal here is then
to extend this lifetime and to keep it
at a target reliability for as long as
possible because nobody wants to be
buying
really fast ssd drives for your laptops
that work really great for three months
and then crash
uh just to give you a and sort of a
sense of how severe these numbers are
tlc device is a sort of state-of-the-art
device it refers to a technology that
stores three bits per cell we'll talk
more about that technology in the
context of some coding solutions uh
during the talk
without doing anything special to it
without doing any coding you can wear
out the device in a matter of months
which is really really really
pessimistic
okay so now you see there is a broad
range of problems that we are
encountering
and of course coding based solutions
have been with data storage from day one
and they have actually been used very
successfully in a range of data storage
systems
however due to these strong asymmetries
that span both time and space
now there are a lot of opportunities to
innovate in coding beyond the hamming
metric in fact we will appeal to some
existing old results in coding theory
that have found a new home in the
context of nvms and also develop some
new techniques at the same time
okay so um uh today i will share with
you some of the recent results of ours
in the context that are coding inspired
approaches to improving or addressing
the flash and reliability so we'll talk
a bit about so-called graded b data
correcting codes for variability within
the cell
we'll talk about some new results on
bomb coding to defer costly races
we'll talk about constraint rank
modulation to mitigate inter-cell
interference
a new type of data
thresholding called the dynamic
thresholding that
attempts to do error balancing and i
will vary belief we described
a class of graph based codes notably a
non-binary ldpc codes that are optimized
for flash
okay in the end of the talk and i think
this is probably of most interest i will
also discuss a range of other problems
that are both coding and not just coding
based that can be
studied in the context of improving
reliability of these memory devices
okay so let's get started as we already
established flash memories possess
strong asymmetry
um so what i'm showing here is and this
this was collected from a real on a real
tlc device again tlc it is a device that
stores three bits per cell that's just
the naming we use so here what we show
is that we did a careful data collection
and we noticed that uh most of the time
out of three bits in error uh
out of three bits and style only one
beta was in error
frequently much less frequent was the
two bits were in error and even less
frequently were three bits in our okay
so let's see how we can exploit that so
then the goal is to actually construct a
coding scheme that
works rather than ignores these
properties of the arrow patterns that we
have encountered let's do an example
so suppose this sequence is stored the
way i'm grouping the information here is
in triplets so each triplet corresponds
to one cell since we are storing three
bits per cell now i'm just unfolding
them in a long sequence of zeros and
ones so you can think of this how many
we have one two three four five six
cells each storing three bits
because of the errors that have happened
for a variety of reasons
that we mentioned before what we see is
not what we stored originally in in fact
i'm marking them in color where the
differences are
there are many different ways in which
you can characterize these types of
errors you can say well okay let me just
look at them at a symbol level in groups
of three you can say well there were
three symbols that were in error namely
i'm just looking at the collection of
triplets that have experienced
some errors right there's three of them
now i can be a little bit more refined
and say
well not only there were three symbols
in error but whenever the error occurred
uh at most the number of errors that i
ceased to
okay just based on this example that we
see i can be even more refined than that
and say
well there were three symbols in error
there were at most two iranian bits per
iranian symbol and it occurred exactly
here
and there was only one symbol that had
one billion errors so the centers is a
little bit convoluted at the moment but
the idea is that what we want to capture
here is the fact that most of the time
there was a very few number of bits per
in our perineus symbol however we do
want to account for the fact that there
may be some errors that have that inc
have more than one bit scenario so how
we can what are the kind of codes that
we would uh build for this
if you're looking only at the symbol
level you say okay let me then just go
and pick up a standard symmetric error t
symbol error correcting code
in this case perhaps we can look a code
that corrects t symbols
i have not introduced the code but this
is how we would do it
t symbols which has at most albeit
scenario
and sort of based on this
sentence under item three
i can define a code that has more
parameters associated with it in fact it
has four parameters parameters t1 and t2
will collectively
guide me in number of iranian symbols
that i seek to correct and l1 and l2 i
will uh tell me how many iranian bits
per nano symbols i want to correct the
reason why this sentence is exactly like
this is actually for mathematical
reasons when we built our codes
okay so here is one way of constructing
these codes um
the construction is based on tensor
product operations so the idea here is
that we are actually utilizing as
underlying codes our existing
symmetrical correcting codes but we are
combining them in a careful way so is to
be able to correct the error patterns of
the type that exactly we see in practice
if we were to just blindly apply
symmetric error correcting codes we are
doing more than we should because then
we are accounting for the error
correcting capability for the type of
errors that may not exist
okay so we start with the binary code h
just a regular binary code h that has
error correction capability l2
which has a sub
which has a parity check matrix h rather
whose
sub a matrix has a corresponds to a code
that has error correction capability l1
then we introduce two additional
non-binary codes symmetric non-binary
codes they're defined over appropriately
chosen fields so that these operations
work out and we can apply tensor product
operations
they are both against symmetric error
correcting one has zero correction
capability t one plus t two the wider
one has the correction capability t two
when you put everything together indeed
we have we uh get a parity check matrix
of a code that exactly corrects the type
of errors that we're interested in
namely those
that have a total number of uranium
symbols governed by t1 plus t2 of which
at most e2 will have no more than l2
errors
erranus bits i should point out that
this was inspired by early work by jack
wool from 1960s when he proposed a
scheme that only has one tensor product
operation clearly this was not in the
context of flash this was in the context
of correcting burst of errors so we have
been able to sort of go back uh uh go
back in the past and dig up some old
results that have can serve as a
starting point and then built upon them
uh to provide the family of codes that
are actually fit the needs of what we're
looking for in flash
slight extension
not only there is a variability amongst
the errors within a cell
some cells are just naturally better or
worse than others in fact we also
observed and some other people have
observed that some cells are just
naturally more unreliable
not many of them they're just some that
are more error-prone
but this is these are sort of orders of
magnitude statements
please don't interpret them as exact
numbers there's a very small fraction of
errors that are counted for sorry a
small fraction of cells that have
accounted for a non-trivial amount of
errors and with a slight modification of
our scheme where in we only offer
limited programming or rather allow
limited programming into those few
select highly unreliable cells we can do
a little bit better in terms of our
construction
so here's one plot
the x-axis is programming erase cycle
this is your lifetime
y-axis is a page error rate you want
that to be as low as possible for as
long as possible
these curves all get worse over time
remember we have that issue of wear out
so things get worse over time
the curve on the the red curve is your
non-binary bch code this is
pretty much what people would do in
practice or even a combination of some
other codes like binary bch code or a
combination of three parallel binary bch
codes these three curves are all
symmetric error correcting codes mind
you for us the errors are not all
created equal and if you just apply
symmetric error correction you are
essentially allowing your code to do
more for you than it does and where you
do you pay the penalty in redundancy so
with the slide so our schemes the
original is in pink and the one that is
modified that only offers limit allows
for limited programming into these
select few cells we can essentially push
this to the right the reason why these
curves start here is because we did not
observe any errors until this this leads
into the lifetime yes can you know in
advance
yeah so there are many different ways in
which you can do that for example a cell
that has there are different mechanisms
to do that uh there here is one way to
do it um the cells that have repeatedly
give you a uranus outputs on on some
prescribed number of most recent rights
for us actually it was sufficient to
only identify two such cells in our
example so two out of million is is not
it was not really a big deal to find is
this
is this
this
is
on a real step no no this is on a real
device this is on a real device so the
coding the entire coding machinery is
developed independent of the device but
in the sort of spirit of this workshop
we went from practice which is data
collection this motivated the
development of new coding scheme and
then we tested this back on this so what
i'm showing here is that for a tlc flash
device which is the one that stores
three bits per cell but number three is
completely uh is a parameter that we can
tune it is not native to us
how is that easy to actually do yeah we
have we have so this was part of this
work was done in collaboration under an
nsf project with a colleagues from uc
san diego who were kind enough to share
some of these um
access to flash devices that we were
able to test this on so you can do you
actually probe the cells and see you
know right see what you've gotten
so there's
that's essentially how you have to do it
all right uh
another sort of coding inspired approach
uh again a little bit of uh flashback
right once memories is something that
was developed actually a long time ago
uh by revisting shamir in 30 years ago
and then other people have worked on
this problem
and here is how it goes here uh
think of it uh for people for whom this
will be uh for some of you this will be
a good analogy for younger audience
probably not think of a punch card
okay so think of a punch card you a
punch the card
once you punch it you can't unpunch it
but even when you punch it you can the
unpunched positions you can still keep
punching and that's how you can store
more data
so what this means if you think of it as
a cell
cells are irreversibly programmed from
zero to one
and uh
that means that if we invoke some kind
of coding mechanism we can write
additional information on top of
previously stored information if you can
combine some new coding techniques the
reason why this is interesting now is
that you can write information on top of
previously stored information without
invoking this expensive erase and
remember for us a raise is a very
expensive operation and in fact uh this
uh connections for flash by flash were
recognized by andrew jiang and brook and
jacoby and siegel and so forth
so one
i will introduce one of our recent
schemes
first let me walk you through how a code
like this would work okay so this
original code is due to reverse and
shamir from 1982. so here is how it
works you have an information which only
in our case it's a very simple code you
take two bits you encode it into three
bits here is an example everything is
done according to this table
let's say you want to do this for two
rights so we always look at a prescribed
number of rights because things become
progressively more difficult as the
number of rights increase and you it's
hard to maintain this constraint that we
want to can happen that we don't want to
go back from one to zero
in any case let's do an example in write
one you start with 0 1 and according to
our table you encode 0 0 1.
on write 2 you go to the table
you want to encode let's say this
message 1 0 so you would store 1 0 1
so notice that at least in this example
one zero one became 101 so we really
never had the case that one transitioned
back to zero so you can write 101 on top
of zero zero one
and in fact this was actually very
carefully constructed table and uh you
can check uh that indeed all these
transitions are possible if you were to
write the same information twice you
wouldn't go from one zero like for
example you want to write one 1 twice
you wouldn't go from 1 0 1 to 0 1 1
because that would be illegal you just
stay at whatever you had encoded already
in any case all these possible
combinations of writing two bits twice
work
and uh and that is your that is
essentially the reason original code
okay so we need a few definitions we are
looking to construct a code that
satisfies a so-called vom constraint in
the sense it's a very natural constraint
now that we have seen an example
j is our generation or number of writes
that we're going to execute this this is
we can uh
rivers and shamir code was over a binary
alphabet we're also interested in
extending this to non-binary but it's
given the interest in very dense
non-volatile memories nowadays so we're
looking to
build codes such that on every
subsequent generation what you write is
always sits on top of what you have
previously written irrespective of what
you have previously written
some rate is the quantity that we are
interested in so we want to be able to
store as many
code words as possible so we are looking
for codes of having high sum rates if mj
is the number of code words you can
store a generation j then the rate at
that generation is log mj over n if
you're encoding over n cells and the sum
rate is simply the sum of four possible
rates capacity of course is the best you
can do
capacity in the example that we have
seen is 158 and that code itself gave
you 133.
okay so recent work on this topic has
given the sort of
applicability to this type of codes to
non-volatile memories there's been a lot
of very nice recent work in the context
of binary one
what i will show to you today is one of
our recent results on non-binary
okay so how can we yes please
i saw there is the the combinatorial
formula for this yes that is basically
shows
that was that was also due to reverse
and shamir yes these are results back
from the 1980s yes
uh it is log n plus t minus one choose
uh log of computatorial term the very
simple combinatorial terms it's easy to
plug in
for the sum rate
uh okay
all right so now we have some intuition
of how to build a binary uh ld sorry
even an ldpc binary one code and like i
said thank you and like i said these
results have been since most recently
very uh
significantly extended but now you've
seen an example how this works okay let
me show you an example of a non-binary
to write one code uh here in order for
to make the construction work we require
the number of levels to be a number that
is divisible by three
so the total number of levels is such
that cubic is such that the total number
of levels is q and q plus 1 is divisible
by 3.
so now i'm going to divide these levels
into groups of
l
so the first subset are levels zero
through l minus one the second subset is
l minus one to two l minus one so notice
that l minus one is common so these are
not partitions they have slight overlap
and then third subset is from two
to l minus 1 to 3 l minus 1 for the
total okay here is the way we can encode
so suppose we have available a binary to
write one code
and i just show you an example of that
one that was that you reversed and
shameer code
on the first right we're going to pick
some arbitrary message
of length n over zl so it's arbitrary
message of length n
you're going to pick a first generation
code word from our constituent binary of
code we saw an example of the one of
length input size two length three
and depending on what the entries in
that
code word are in in in entries in the
code word u r we are going to write
either in the position
m i uh
entering you're going to write in that
position either value mi or mi plus l
where mi is the
entry in your message
so what that means
that means on the first right you only
you're restricted to only right to these
first and second subsets right so you're
only writing to lower levels then
tuition being is that you don't want to
write up too high because then it's
going to eat up a way for what you can
do later okay
on the second right you pick a different
message again arbitrary message
uh you pick a second generation code
word from your form your underlying code
and now again you either write in the
value either that s i is the ith entry
in your new messages you either write
value s i plus l minus 1 or l i plus 2 l
minus 1.
and so what that means here you're only
writing on the second and the third
subset okay so if you do this carefully
as we have done here you're guaranteed
that you're only going up you know
you're sort of avoiding these illegal
transitions
uh and here is just an example we've
seen this table before let me just walk
you through these numbers
so let's say your information is uh 0 1
that you want thank you i'll probably
just keep some other examples okay 0 1
according to our reverse and shamir code
we map that to 0 0 1.
uh your input message is 0 1 2 is zero
one two again
so essentially this reverse and schemer
code word modulates these values so zero
stays at zero one stays at one but two
now becomes five
and likewise here
um
one one one modulates two one two so it
becomes seven six seven as you can see
this message strictly sits on top of
this message
okay um
all right uh so this uh
this very simple construction that i've
just shown you offers the the codes of
some rate of 4.5 the capacity is again
according to the same calculation this
is 517.
these are very short codes your question
is can you do better in fact you can and
we have developed a
new code family that is just a little
bit more combinatorial involved but it
sort of carries over a similar type of
intuition that we've seen in this
example
here we just instead of using one
constituent code we're using three
constituent codes and uh one code is
quaternary code with the low numbers of
twos and threes and whatever was not
encoded in that code we use that
leftover information to encode using two
constituent binary bomb codes and this
is these are the new summaries that we
have
been able to achieve and these are this
this is the capacity and as far as we
know this is the best you can do this
also extends to this case where you uh
restrict yourself to have the same
number of rights same number of code
words on each right
okay uh here's here's another way of
looking at things
rank modulation is a new data
representation it was pioneered by
andrew giang
and here the key idea is that instead of
representing values in the absolute
terms which corresponds to threshold
voltages y-axis threshold voltages you
represent information in terms of their
relative ranking
okay so if these are the volt threshold
voltage threshold voltage is essentially
how much it corresponds to the
information stored in a cell essentially
how much voltage do you need to turn on
the cell
okay so suppose these are the absolute
values for the voltages 2.8 1.5 2.6 and
so forth okay so instead of looking
these numbers in the absolute terms
let's just look at the ranking so this
would be first one second one third
fourth and fifth so this now induces the
permutation over integers of from the
set one through five off one three two
four and five right what are some advan
sorry what are some advantages of this
scheme
remember wear out was one of the
problems we want to deal with just
imagine if everything drops down
together uniformly then the relative
ordering is preserved so this is one of
the advantages of the scheme
however intercell coupling is a problem
still in rank modulation in the sense
that inadvertent charges can change cell
rankings and here is an example to
illustrate why this is so suppose we
start with this setup where our original
permutation is 1 2 through 10 because
this one is the highest and this one is
the lowest then they all go down
now suppose this this is the permutation
we start with in our rank modulation now
suppose we want to represent a new
permutation okay so how we do that you
want to represent a new permutation we
need to inject just enough charge in
corresponding entries to push them
enough to change the relative ordering
so this one must be the highest and this
one must deny the second highest but see
like i'm adding a lot of charge in these
two cells and interstellar interference
occurs when two cells are
strongly programmed if you will and then
something happens in the middle
okay
all right so uh
as we say here now we inadvertently
raised the level of
cell okay all right i'll just speed up
okay um
block is so um
so you we can
essentially what we come to is that we
get the permutation that we didn't want
right so then the idea is that
now we have even though there was only
one cell that was increased incorrectly
we have induced some positions in
permutation that are now in error
so the idea now is to constrain the
difference between adjacent cells
adjacent cell ranks and for that we
introduce the notion of a single
neighbor k constraint and so basic idea
is to now study
uh
to study permutations that are
constrained
so not all permutations but certain
constraint permutations for example this
permutation meets a two constraint
because there is no gap more than two
but it does not meet one constraint
because one and two for example yeah
differ by two
okay um
as one of our results we have actually
did a count of all possible uh
permutations constraints permutations
under the
constraint that we have
we have introduced we have a lower bound
and upper bound uh
and it uses some combinatorial arguments
to do that
we also computed the capacity of such
codes
both for the polynomial case in terms of
the constraints and for the constant
case and we have also introduced
new i'll just skip some details we have
also introduced new codes that are that
are follow in the class of constraint
permutations and offer error correction
capability we have capacity results and
also asymptotically optimal codes for
that
i'm going to skip this step because i'm
out of time and i'll just show you one
more plot
um okay so we also developed a class of
non-binary ldpc codes that are optimized
for a varying number of reads this is a
these are
codes that provide so-called soft
information which is what people in
practice are very much interested in
here what i'm showing on the x-axis is
the row bit error rate against the frame
error rate
being to the right means it's a stronger
code because you can tolerate more
errors bch code is the one in black and
our codes are are the ones in blue so
they offer superior performance both
relative to binary ldpc codes and
unoptimized non-binary ldpc codes and
optimization has to do with how we
design a code so as to um
overcome these error patterns that we
see in flash there are some publications
of ours on this topic basically covers
the material i said today
there is many other interesting topics
this hopefully will be of interest to
audience here uh in investigation so i
primarily focused on the algebraic
constructions and very briefly on graph
based results
but other modern codes polar spatially
coupled lattice codes there's a lot of
interest in all these for nvms to deal
with all kinds of errors both permanent
and transient errors
how to deal with coding that is attuned
to changing noise characteristics of the
channel
we have a sympathetic optimality in
terms of certain code constructions can
you do better can you have better bounds
what are the complexity and performance
tradeoffs
we are typically interested in worst
case performance however average case
performance may also be of uh value
nvms i talked most
primarily about flash memories there are
other types of non-volatile memories
including pcm phase change memories sdt
ram that also share
some of these operational asymmetries
with flash and in addition have some
other additional properties and they're
all
really primed for new uh coding
inspired approaches that go beyond the
hamming metric
it doesn't have to be coding for the
people who are working on other topics
uh parameter estimations so new signal
processing techniques for characterizing
the channel we used in one of our
experiments and when the question came
up we used actual data but it would be
nice to have a closed form solution for
these channels there is some very recent
work on this topic
people currently use gaussian because
that's just a good starting point but we
all actually already know that this is
not a good model
on
communication methods for flash how to
do detectors for interstellar
interference equalization and so forth
a lot of room left to do capacity
calculations these channels when you
have fixed number of reads become
quantized non-asymptotic performance
analysis
um probability applications the
probabilistic methods and
a little bit more speculative but
perhaps even the usage of interference
alignment type of techniques to address
the issues of interference in these
channels
and i that concludes my talk thank you
very much
maybe one quick question while is
setting up is the question bye no okay
so why don't you sit up with me
oh you're also done yeah yeah okay so
then any question quick question
yes so um
when you're reading a cell you have an a
to d right so if you're going for prefix
or something
what's the trade-off to go into more
bits and then you're looking at
that yeah yeah so that's a few reads is
much better because there is a one of
the things we want to deal with is here
is read latency fewer bits is better
however you have a much better
reliability about the content of the
cell if you have multiple bits multiple
reads rather so typically the most for
example i'm quoting samsung from what
they've told me they don't want to go
above seven but they would prefer to
keep it for atlanta for as long as
possible
and these reads are all one bit reads
right yes so exactly the way it works
you're going to set up multiple
thresholds and then you actually say
because at the end of the day you're
doing the same step comparison are you
to the left or to the right of a
prescribed threshold you have multiple
thresholds so let's say if you have
three thresholds you can if you read all
three thresholds you can say whether you
were in one of the four regions which
three thresholds can determine yes but
placement of the thresholds is actually
a question in its own right because
depending on where you place the
thresholds you're going to induce a
different quantized channel and so if
you induce the wrong quantized channel
then you're building a code for the
wrong channel so there is an issue there
is
ongoing work being done in careful
placement of the threshold reads if you
have if you have a fixed number of rates
yes
uh the last one or the one before the
last one okay yes
they're typically interested in
extremely low frame error rates